Transcriber: Gizem D
Gözden geçirme: Rıza Özdemir
Mosmor olmak üzere olan bir adamımız var.
Yeniden nefes alıyoruz. Çok teşekkürler.
Neil, merdivenden indiğini şu anda
görebiliyoruz.
Ayağım merdivenin son basamağında.
♫ ♫ ♫
♫♫♫♫
Merak ediyorum.
Aranızda küçükken uzaya çıkmak
isteyen var mıydı?
Harika.
Aynı kıvamdaymışız.
Herkesin hayatta çizdiği bir rota var.
Ben de sağlık teknolojileriyle
ilgili ilerledim.
Son 20 yıldır biyofizik alanında
giyilebilir teknolojiler, sanal gerçeklik,
artırılmış gerçeklik üzerine çalışmalar
gerçekleştiriyorum.
Elbette her şey hayal etmekle başladı.
Üniversitedeyim, birinci sınıf.
Birinci dersten çıktık.
Anabilim dalı başkanı hocamızın
yanına gittik.
Hemen gittim.
Hayalimi anlatıyorum.
Artık tahtayı mı göremedim, bir şey
mi yaşadım o anda bilmiyorum.
Hocaya hayalimi anlatırken dedim ki: Hocam
böyle sanki siz ortada olsanız,
havaya yazı yazabilseniz, silebilseniz,
çizebilseniz, biz sizin etrafınızda
olsak, biz de yazabilsek,
biz de çizebilsek dedim.
Hoca bir bana baktı.
Önce ne demek istediğimi anlamaya çalıştı.
Sonra arkasındaki kütüphaneden
bir kitap aldı.
Bir karış kalınlığında A4 büyüklüğünde
Elementler kitabını bana uzattı.
Okumadım bunu oku dedi.
Elbette okumadım.
Yıl 1999 bu arada. Milattan önce.
Muhtemelen salonda o yıllarda
doğmamış olanlar vardır.
Bazen hocanız da olsa hayalinizi kendisine
aktarmaya biliyorsunuz.
Sizin koyduğunuz vizyonu,
gideceği noktayı, düşündüğünüz
şeyleri içeren geçiremeyebiliyorsunuz.
Bu size bazen engel gibi görünüyor ama
aslında sizi güçlendiren bir element.
O kitabı okumadım ama hayal
etmeye devam ettim.
Genel cerrahi uzmanı bir arkadaşımla
sohbet esnasında safra kesesi
ameliyatlarında yaşanan küçük kesi
problemi olduğunu öğrendim.
Konuşuyoruz, beyin fırtınası yapıyoruz.
Ben de o sıralar üniversite son sınıfta
lazerlerin sağlık teknolojisinde
kullanımıyla ilgili tez hazırlıyorum.
Dedim ki şimdi safra kesesi
büyük olduğunda
küçük kesiden dışarı çıkamıyormuş.
Böyle dedim kaz ayağı gibi
bir modelin olsa,
küçük kesiden içeri girsen, safra kesesini
kavrasan lazerle kırsan, aspire etsen
ve tekrar çıksan nasıl olur?
Muhteşem olur dedi.
Hemen açtık Microsoft ofis programını.
Tabi o zamanlar SolidWorks, AutoCAD,
Rhino, 3DMax, Blender bu
programlara haiz değilim.
Microsoft ofisin elle çiz kısmını aştık.
Bilgisayarda modelini
iki boyutlu olarak çizdik
ama patent başvurusu, prototipleme,
girişimcilik, şirket kurma
hiçbir fikrim yoktu.
Hayal etmeye devam ettim.
Doktora tezim sırasında bu sefer ileri
teknolojik bir şirketin yüksek teknolojik
bir makinasını kullanıyorum.
Kanser araştırmaları yapıyoruz.
Kanser araştırmalarımız sırasında da o
makinanın istediğim bazı parametreleri var
O parametreleri--
Arıyorum firmayı bu parametreyi
alabiliyor muyuz? Hayır hocam.
Şunu yapabiliyor muyuz?
Hayır hocam. Bu görüntüyü alabiliyor
muyuz? Hayır hocam.
Hayır, hayır, hayırlara hayır dedim.
Artık benim şirketimi kurmam, üç boyutlu
modellerin tasarımlarımı
gerçekleştirmenin zamanı geldi dedim.
2015′te şirketimi kurdum.
İlk makinamız gerçek zamanlı hücre sayım,
görüntüleme ve analiz cihazının
tasarımını, modellemesini bilgisayarda
gerçekleştirdik.
Üretimini gerçekleştirdik.
Ardından bunlar bir çorap söküğü gibi
ardı arkasına ardı arkası gelmedi.
Bir tane sorunu çözdüğünü zaman diğerini
de çözmeye çalışıyorsunuz.
Yaşadığınız sorunları sorun olarak
görmemeye başlıyorsunuz.
Krizleri fırsata çevirmeye çalışıyorsunuz.
Çözüm odaklı yaklaşmaya başlıyorsunuz.
Bir makina, iki makina, üç el aleti
dört, beş derken
artık bunları diğerlerinin de
yani diğer öğrencilerimin de kullanımına
sunmam gerektiğini düşündüm ve sanal
ortamlarda alan açarak sanal deney
laboratuvarı gerçekleştirdik.
Sanal ameliyatlar, ameliyathaneler
oluşturduk.
Tabii şimdi ben bunları onu yaptık, bunu
yaptık diye anlatıyorum ama sanal
gerçeklik sistemlerinin 1960'larda kaça
indiğini de söylememiz lazım.
Gerçek dünyadayız, evrenimizdeyiz.
Metaverse evreninin yani sanal evrenin
simülasyonlarını oluşturuyoruz.
Üç boyutlu modellemelerini yapıyoruz.
Kaplamalarını, yapısını yapıyoruz.
Animasyonlarını, kodlamalarını
oluşturuyoruz
ve fırsat eşitliği için
ürünler geliştiriyoruz.
Sizlere bazı ürünlerimizi göstereceğim.
Sanal ameliyathaneyi görüyorsunuz.
Açık kalp damar cerrahisi ameliyatlarını
tüm tıp fakültesi öğrencileri istedikleri
yerde, istedikleri zaman, istedikleri
kadar deneyimleme bilirler.
Hem eğitimlerini sanal ortamda tecrübe
ederken
sınavlarını da içeride yapabiliyoruz.
Tiroid kanser ameliyatı uçtan
uca
tüm operasyonu sanal
ortamda yapabilmekteler.
Diğer bir çalışmamız sanal deney
laboratuvarı DNA izolasyonundan
DNA elektroforezine, protein
elektroforezinden kök hücre saflaştırmaya,
PCR analizlerine kadar tıp fakültesi
deneylerinin tamamını
sanal ortamlara aktardık.
Aslında bu yaptığımız çalışmalar 3 önemli
başlığı içeriyordu. 1- Eğitimde fırsat
eşitliği, 2- Malzeme makine teçhizatların
sarfiyatının azaltılması ve bunun
dolayısıyla 3-Karbon ayak izinin ve su
tüketiminin azaltılmasına destek olmak.
Asya'dan Avrupa'ya, Afrika'dan Amerika'ya
fırsat eşitliğini sunuyordu.
Aslında bir cerrahın yaptığı operasyonu
tüm cerrahların, dünyadaki tüm
cerrahların görüp görebilmesini sağlamak.
Bir kongre merkezi tasarlamak, içerisinde
tüm uzmanlık alanına sahip kişilerin
tecrübe paylaşımlarını sağlamak.
Fütüristik deney laboratuvarları kurarak
tüm deneylerin, eğitimlerin içeride
verilebilmesi sağlamak.
Şu anda görmüş olduğunuzda cerrahi eğitim
alanımız istediğiniz cerrahi anabilim
dalını seçmek suretiyle o alana
giriş ışınını anlıyorsunuz.
İçerisinde tomografi, ultrason, emar
videolarını dev monitörlerde görüyorsunuz.
Hastalığa dair olan ürünlere X-ray
görüntüsü olabilir, patoloji sonucu
olabilir, fotoğraf videoları olabilir
etrafında görebiliyorsunuz.
Ve 3 boyutlu modeli yani hastalığa
dair organın üç boyutlu
İçerdeki avatarlar, cerrah avatarlar.
Siz gözlüğünüzü takıp
öğrenci olarak içeridesiniz.
Hocamız gözlüğünü takıp cerrahi uzmanı
olarak eğitimi veren kişi olarak içerde
çoklu kullanıcılı platformlarda eğitimler
gerçekleştirilebilecek platformları
tasarlıyoruz.
Kanser hastası çocuklarımızı düşündük.
Uzun süre hastanede yatıyorlar ve bu
süreçte psikolojilerine dair artı değer
sağlayacak bir ürün geliştirmek istedik.
Gözlüğü taktıklarında kendilerini
bir uzay gemisinde buluyorlar.
Güneş sisteminin içerisinde gezegenlerin
arasında geziyorlar.
Ve ardından bizim rota META evreninde
bir sergi salonuna varıyorlar.
Burada da Afrika fotoğraflarının arasında
NTF alanında geziyorlar.
Hem psikolojik olarak daha iyi
hissediyorlar hem de ağrı hislerinin de
daha düşük olduğu bilimsel
makalelerde tespit edilmiş.
Pandemi sürecinde 65 yaş üstü hastalarımız
uzun süre evden çıkamadılar.
Evet 65 yaş üstü çıkamadı ama bunun
yanında sarkopeni hastaları,
müsküler distrofi hastaları da vardı.
Kas kayıpları olan hastalar eğer egzersiz
yapmazlarsa kas kayıpları daha da yüksek
değerlere çıkıyordu.
Biz de sanal spor merkezleri tasarlayarak
bir gözlüğü taktıklarında isterlerse
kendilerini bir adada, isterlerse ormanda,
isterlerse de Olimpiyat Stadyumu'nda
bulmalarını sağlayacak sanal
spor merkezleri tasarladık.
Boks yapabiliyorlar, dart atabiliyorlar,
kürek çekebilir, tenis oynayabilir, masa
tenisi oynayabilir, aklınıza gelen tüm
sporları içeride gerçekleştirmek
suretiyle kas kayıplarının en aza
indirilmesini sağlamak üzere
çalışmalarımızı gerçekleştirdik.
Evet, sağlık alanında ürünler geliştirdik
ama bir taraftan da olimpiyat
oyuncularıyla da çalıştık.
Olimpiyatlara hazırlanan sporcularımızın
hazırlık yani fiziki egzersiz öncesi
sanal ortamda antrenman yapmalarını
sağlayan platformlar, tesisler
gerçekleştirdik.
Dijital rota meta evrenimizde
dijital evren yapmadık.
Kendi tasarlamış olduğumuz mimarilerin
içerisinde sanal üniversite, sanal hastane
sanal kongre merkezleri, uzay
merkezi, fütüristik sınıflar aklınıza
gelen her şeyi... Sınır Sizsiniz’i
gerçekleştirmeye çalıştık.
2030 yılına kadar
sürdürülebilir kalkınma için
üç işin başarılması hedeflenmiştir.
Bir eşitsizlik, iki adaletsizlik,
üç iklim değişikliği.
Yaptığımız çalışmalarda gördük ki biz
aslında eğitimde, sağlıkta fırsat
eşitliğine değer sağlıyoruz.
Kadın erkek demeden herkesin kullanımına
yarayacak ürünler geliştiriyoruz.
Bir taraftan iklim değişikliklerine
artı değer sağlıyoruz.
Çünkü ihracat yapan firmaların ihracat
hususunda kullanacakları
sanal şov odaları tasarlıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla numune üretimini
ortadan kaldırıyoruz.
Makine teçhizat ağların sanalda
eğitimini veriyoruz.
Dolayısıyla karbon ayak izi, su ayak
izinin en aza indirilmesini sağlıyoruz.
En önemli 17'nci madde ise bu üç başarının
3 işin başarılması için 17
madde konulmuştur.
17'nci madde ortak amaçlar
için iş birliği.
Biz hep birlikte güçlüyüz.
İşbirliği güç birliği yaptığımızda
geleceğimizi, kurtarıcı ağımızı
düşünüyoruz.
İnsanlığın geleceği için, doğanın geleceği
için yani hepimizin geleceği
için bu çalışmaları gerçekleştiriyoruz.
Kadın erkek demeden, zorluklara göğüs
gererek hayır diyenlerin karşınızda çok
olacağı bir noktadasınız.
Hayır diyenlere hayır diyin.
Hayallerinize sarılarak, aşkla
sarılarak devam edin.
Hayal et gerçek olsun.